[Musique]
bonsoir je m'appelle les dix jansson
je viens de la région parisienne je suis
né j'ai grandi et je vis toujours avec
mes trois enfants en seine saint denis
dans le 93
ce département je laime énormément il
m'a forgé
il m'a appris beaucoup de choses aussi
l'école de la vie alors - j'ai cette
double culture
ma mère est marocaine et mon papa est
martiniquais
je suis très fier de mes parents j'ai
grandi dans un petit pavillon de la
seine-saint-denis où l'amour l'entr'aide
la solidarité a fait partie de notre
éducation
ce soir j'ai envie de vous parler du
plus beau métier du monde
un métier qui accompagnent les autres
qui aide les autres et qui vient au
secours des autres
ce métier là si le métier de mon papa
ce héros mon héros mon père a été
longtemps gardien de la paix et ouais si
vous saviez tous ces maux qui se cache
derrière cette fonction je me rappelle
quand j'étais tout petit je le regarde
et je l'espionnaient enfilé son uniforme
mettre son arme de service et partir
travailler
mon père a été gardien de la paix
pendant 25 ans il a fini sa carrière au
sein de la bac du 93 la brigade
anticriminalité j'avais 10 ans quand
j'ai vu mon peut pas changer
s'isoler simon
famille n'existe presque plus alors dès
ce soir et je voyais mon papa rentré
alcoolisé fatigué blessés
j'étais tout petit mais je sentais qu'il
y avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
avec cette fonction mon père mon héros
si fort et si faible à la fois je me
rappelle une date parce que j'ai la
mémoire des dates et oui comme tout le
monde il ya des dates comme ça qui reste
fort j'ai dans le coeur et dans la tête
c'est un samedi soir en 1996 j'avais 14
ans on était tranquillement installé au
salon une dispute éclate comme une
pendule en en avoir un petit peu partout
dans les couples mon père et ma mère se
chargent mari mon père mon talent étage
ma mère me dit c'est bizarre j'ai un
mauvais pressentiment
localement elle le suit et la très vite
elle redescend et elle nous dit sortez
votre papa a pris son arme sortait alors
on sort de la maison
que faire on attend maman qu'est ce
qu'on fait on rentre à la maison
peut-être qu'ils se calment et moi j'ai
trop peur j'ai 14 ans et j'ai trop peur
j'ai pas envie de rentrer à la maison
parce que si mon père a pris son arme je
sais pas ce qui va faire avec
alors j'ai un site ma mère allait au
commissariat qui est pas très loin un
deux trois minutes à pied je me suis dit
allez on ne vous allez voir les
collègues un papa ils vont réussir à le
calmer
alors on y va au commissariat en pyjama
en marche
je me rappelle j'ai mon petit frère dans
la main mon petit frère lui il avait 12
ans il était tétanisé voulait même
parler alors on marche comme ça on veut
au commissariat et là on rencontre une
fonctionnaire en lui explique elle nous
dit vous inquiétez pas ça va aller vous
êtes sûr que vous voulez qu'on
intervienne mois à 14 ans je comprends
pas pourquoi nous pose la question
bah oui on est sûr il faut y aller
madame il a pris son arme il nous dit
allez retourner devant chez vous ne vous
inquiétez pas un véhicule va arriver et
j'ai toujours mon petit frère dans la
main on retourne devant le pavillon et
on n'attend pas trop près pas trop loin
on attend patiemment une voiture arrive
avec les gyrophares les gyrophares et
résonne partout dans tout le petit
lotissement qui était bien tranquille 1
samedi soir
et là je me dis il va se passer quelque
chose de grave
alors j'attends toujours et conti frère
dans la main personne ne dit rien on
attend et là il demande à ma mère
d'ouvrir le pavillon parce qu'ils
peuvent pas intervenir comme ça ma mère
ouvre le pavillon elle ressort et là des
fonctionnaires de police rentre
ils sont quatre j'attends avec mon petit
frère dans la main et la satire dans ma
maison ça tire une deux trois quatre
fois des échanges de coups de feu
je suis toujours là devant place devant
le pavillon j'attends patiemment une
fonctionnaire de police ressort elle
s'écroule pas très loin de nous j'avais
l'impression que je pouvais aller la
voir la secourir on est tétanisé avec
mon petit frère que je tient dans la
main et on attend ces quelques minutes
en vérité ce sont des heures qui passent
mais on est toujours là attendre
deuxième fois des coups de feu retentit
ça s'arrête et un autre coup de feu un
seul qui résonne en moi
encore aujourd'hui alors je vous parle
je vois mon père qui sort sur un
brancard avec une couverture de survie
on comprend pas ce qui se passe personne
ne nous dit rien mais j'ai toujours mon
petit frère dans la main et j'attends et
là on est on écoute les adultes et on
comprend que mon père a fait une
tentative de suicide parce que les
adultes quand ils parlent entre eux et
oubliez des enfants bien évidemment mon
père quelques jours après a été déclaré
coupable d'avoir mis en danger sa
famille d'avoir tiré sur des
fonctionnaires donc j'ai eu un papa
mon héros on policiers qui d'un coup est
devenu prisonnier
vous savez quand on est issu d'une
famille une position vie police on mange
police on va en colonie avec des enfants
de policiers à ce moment là il n'y avait
plus de policiers autour de nous cette
famille qu'on aimait tant nous a tourné
le dos mon père n'a jamais voulu qu'on
aille le voir au milieu carcéral il
disait que c'était pas un endroit pour
nous alors j'ai grandi à 14 ans avec ce
traumatisme
on n'a jamais été suivi par l'éducateur
n'est pas un psychologue
aucun accompagnement d'adultes alors
j'ai nourri en moins une violence
extrême
une violence envers moi même et envers
les autres je refusais qu'un adulte me
parle mort donne quoi que ce soit c'est
trop facile
vous étiez pas là quand j'en avais
besoin alors je deviens un voleur
violente je dû rentrer dans la primaube
délinquance de 14 ans à 17 ans jusqu'au
jour où je rencontre un juge monsieur
rosenberg au tribunal de bobigny ce
monsieur prend le temps de me parler
d'auto destruction
il essaye de comprendre mon dossier il
comprend pas pourquoi une fille comme
moi n'a pas été suivie ou n'a pas été
accompagnée il parle de failles
je le sens énervé à travers de lui je
ressemble beaucoup de choses et beaucoup
d'amour
il me dit vous savez mademoiselle des
personnes comme vous j'en croise tous
les jours vous vous auto détruisez alors
à partir d'aujourd'hui vous avez un
choix à faire soit vous continuez
et puis dans les meilleurs des cas vous
serez incarcérés ou soit vous arrêtez
vous prenez conscience là maintenant
aujourd'hui que vous êtes maître de
votre destin
j'ai 17 ans ce dialogue
ce juge m'a changé à fait pu ajouter ma
voix
j'ai décidé d'être une nati fille
malheureusement j'avais raté mon cursus
scolaire ge ge est arrivé en première
année de bac pro si je me rappelle bien
j'ai arrêté l'école entre temps j'ai
décidé de fonder une famille quelques
années plus tard à 21 ans je suis mère
épanouie j'ai quitté le 93 pour boulogne
billancourt et ça va mieux
un soir de l'année 2005
mon téléphone sonne
ma mère m'appelle laetitia ya un
problème
ton petit frère est incarcéré mon petit
frère vous rappeler celui que tenait par
la main
mon petit frère en prison pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'il a fait violence outrage
rébellion et incitation à l'émeute
face aux forces de l'ordre j'ai envie de
prendre sa place à ce moment là en
vérité c'est moi qui aurait dû être là
bas j'ai fauté je vais montrer le
mauvais exemple pendant tant d'années je
n'ai pas tenu la main je vais pas
accompagné je n'avais pas écouté
il a vécu le même traumatisme que moi
mais lui c'est un homme noir de banlieue
parisienne à casquette
vous savez n'est une grande différence
être une femme en banlieue être un homme
en banlieue cette pression sociale que
vivent des jeunes de quartier il faut il
vivre pour y croire
alors mon frère a été incarcéré pendant
six mois à la prison de fleury mérogis
je suis allé le voir en parloir j'ai
essayé de montrer que j'étais là que je
pouvais le soutenir et il est sorti six
mois après on continue notre vie et en
2008 un autre coup de téléphone
laetitia ton frère est à nouveau
incarcéré le même toujours celui que je
tenais par la main mon petit bout de
frère incarcéré un garçon aussi gentil
avec le coeur sur la main
mais ça les juges il ne le vois pas
comme ça ils voient toujours comme un
grand noir de quartier qui ne parlent
pas qui ne s'exprime pas parce que lui
aussi il a vécu le même traumatisme que
moi mais n'arrivent pas de mettre des
mots sur ses maux et de toute façon il
n'y a personne pour l'écouter
alors mon frère est à nouveau incarcéré
une deuxième fois en 2008
et là je prends le temps de réfléchir de
comprendre quels sont les processus de
réinsertion pour un jeune prisonnier en
france un prisonnier d'hier ne serait
pas un citoyen de demain alors on met
des oeillères
on parle pas du milieu carcéral on n'a
pas envie ce sont des délinquants de
toute façon 6 y sont c'est parce qu'ils
ont commis un délit c'est leur place
mais un jour ils feront de place sur la
société à côté de vous ce seront
peut-être vos voisins alors je
m'intéresse je rencontre monsieur
jacques lesage de la haye c'est un
spécialiste pardon de l'incarcération
française il m'apprend plein de choses
depuis mai 68 a maintenant savez vous
que dans le milieu carcéral
il ya trois fois plus de suicides en
milieu ouvert que la surpopulation
excède on à 139 % aujourd'hui
dernièrement il ya un jeune aymeric en
mars 25 ans qui s'est donné la mort
alors qu'il devait sortir quelques jours
après il avait été incarcéré parce qu'il
avait pas payer ses amendes
eh ouais alors je me suis longuement
longuement entretenu avec des
sociologues pour comprendre j'ai
rencontré des familles de victimes des
familles de détenus et je me suis dit
mon frère entrer dans un cercle vicieux
et ce cercle vicieux je n'ai pas envie
que d'autres y passe alors j'ai créé ma
structure associative zonzon 93 et ouais
le nom tout de suite ça mais ça met tout
le monde d'accord
chez nous en banlieue on aime bien quand
on fait la culture du loisir la fête
couscous ou le colombo mais quand on
veut sensibiliser aux jeunes à la
réalité du monde carcéral c'est tout de
suite plus compliqué ma structure
associative accompagne depuis dix ans
des centaines de jeunes on les
sensibilise à la réalité du monde
carcéral
on fait de la prévention la prévention
aux addictions la prévention
tarik on accompagne les familles de
victimes
les jeunes victimes parce qu'un enfant
en danger hier risque d'être un enfant
dangereux demain de 10 on est passé à
300 accompagnement en janvier honig
n'augurera notre deuxième structure à
bobigny dédié aux filles vous savez j'ai
aussi un autre coup de téléphone en mars
de cette année et ja oui bonjour c'est
l'elysée les lis quoi vous venez d'être
nommé par le président de la république
conseillère présidentielle des villes
cette fonction consiste à conseiller le
président de la république sur toutes
les questions relatives au quartier qui
aurait pu imaginer que laeticia à 14 ans
et puis maintenant à 36 ans serait
conseillère présidentielle des villes
même moi je n'aurais pas pu imaginer
je me rappelle encore d'un entretien
avec une déléguée du préfet qui me
disait letia votre projet les trois
ambitieux sachez que madame que
l'ambition me permet de rester là debout
et d'avancer
il ya deux mots qui résonne en moi
l'espoir et l'amour
alors on intervient auprès des foyers de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance pour leur
dire qu'il ya une vie après ça eh ouais
aujourd'hui ce que je vous propose c'est
de venir avec nous dans notre premier
réseau nationale d'entraidé de
solidarité
l'idée est d'échanger même virtuellement
de créer des ponts entre les milieux
ruraux et les milieux urbains entre les
jeunes et les personnes âgées entre les
forces de l'ordre et la jeunesse
vous savez je suis persuadé d'une chose
c'est que nous avons besoin de vous pour
accompagner au mieux la jeunesse de
france merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]